so everybody's an influencer which one
are you
um
I'm a data scientist and my thesis dealt
with classifying on online persuasion
so persuasion is a subtopic of influence
and when we were talking about influence
we were talking about the who the where
and the how
in this lecture we're going to focus on
The Who
who influenced us
and
well when we're talking about
influencers there are actually a few
methods to measure we want to measure
the participation we want to measure the
visibility and want to see the position
on a topic on and the position on a
social network
so let's get a little bit technical
when we're talking about the
participation or activities we're
actually talking about the amount of
tweets and retweets and mentioning other
users and so on and the likes and and it
depends on the type of social platform
when we're talking about visibility is
we're talking about the amount of
retweets likes and mentioning that the
user gets from other users
um when we're
talking about identifying types of you
of influencers and we will use social
network analysis or graph Theory
um and if we just translate that to
python a great package to do so is
Network X
so when we were talking about a social
network or graph we're actually talking
about people and from followers or
friendships and so on and a social
network can be other either directed or
undirected
so this is the directed
um graph of a strong social network
uh that that doesn't wait I mean the
each one of the Arches between two notes
each one of those are a node a doesn't
point there are the same a follow b b
follow a c follow B and so on
and
this is an undirected a graph which
means it is stuck a little bit like
friends in Facebook either that
um in in contracts to a followers in
Instagram or Twitter
um a network can be valued and waited or
it can be
um unweighted and and each one of the
Arches weight is the same
uh when we're talking about degrees
and centrality degrees we want to see
the number of artists that come out of a
node
um and
when we are measuring participation we
are measuring the out degree and when
we're measuring visibility we're
measuring the in degree of a specific
node of a specific user our degree is
how many tweets a user have and
visibility and in degree is how many
mentioned the user is a gets
so this was visibility and participation
but what about the clear position on a
topic
um this graph is from the um a great
article a paper that is written down
down here that measure activity prone
against and the prime minister in Brazil
and
in the three days around the the
election
so this is prone against
um and what they
what the clear position on the topic
um usually when
when we have controversies online they
are much more engaging
um as in we like to fight we like to
argue we this is a what makes
controversy topics much more engaging
so when we're actually talking about
this position on a topic we're searching
for the modularity of it to see the
communities
and
so
the community can actually change we can
see them did more dollarity uh through
three days around the election that it's
it doesn't look the same
so the amount of the um the way the I
mean people can change your views but as
long as they have a specific
um
position on a topic this can
um can be used to identify them as a
specific type of an influencer and what
they actually talked about in that paper
is that whether or not you have a
political position
methods if you have and if you have
clear pres a clear position then and you
have an in high in degree you're an
opinion you're an opinion leader if you
have an eye out degree you're an
activist if you don't have a clear
position you might be an influential
informational influencer like news
outlet and you can also be a journalist
or a boat
so this was the positional topic but
then we have a position on a network
we're talking about between centrality
we're talking about the the link between
two groups of information the
information Hub the one that that is
accountable for the diffusion of
information from one side to another
so this is another article that what
they talked about is again you have the
influential
influencers with the I hint degree with
the influencers with the high out degree
but you also have the informational book
the information Brokers that have a high
between between us
so which one are you
do you have an high in degree high
visibility are you an information Source
do you have a clear position are you an
opinion leader
do you not to have a clear position
maybe you're just in some maybe it's
just some kind of a news Outlet
do you have an eye out degree High
participation
Are you a discriminator
if you have a clear position you're an
activist if you don't maybe it's a bot
if you ever in between us you're a
broker of information you will main Hub
where information go from one side to
another
and why does it even matter
as you can see in the picture
each one of us
um have the information of any kind of
piece of information in their finger
tips
even children and other people that
cannot quite filter whether or not
um it's appropriate for them to consume
that piece of information or or not
so maybe we need to take that with a
little bit with a pinch of salt
thank you